[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
un menu dont jal un bon je vois rouge
merci beaucoup d'être avec nos ministes
de la transformation et de la fonction
publique on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bonjour pascal jalabert du
groupe ebra les journaux régionaux de
l'est de la france
on commence bien sûr par cette crise
sanitaire et c'est le début aujourd'hui
de la vaccination pour les plus de 75
ans aurait pas d' ainsi que pour les
personnes qui ont des pathologies à très
haut risque et il ya une inquiétude
ce week end est liée aux annonces de
pfizer qui annonce un retard de
livraison qui ne sera finalement que
d'une semaine à priori mais quand même
ça inquiète
est-ce que clairement il ya un risque de
pénurie du lac sans france alors déjà
moi je pense qu'il faut revenir à le
risque qui était le nôtre il ya encore
quelques semaines c'est que trop peu de
français à l'époque avait envie de se
faire vacciner est donc déjà la première
chose c'est qu'on a gagné une première
bataille et c'est de la confiance
aujourd'hui on a plus de 55% des
français qui veulent se faire vacciner
c'est une bonne nouvelle parce que 11,7
vaccin n'est efficace que si on est
nombreux à ce maxi donc ça je pensais
qu'à un point sur lequel il faut qu'on
soit rassurant et objectifs le deuxième
enjeu vous le dites c'est
qu'effectivement on cherche à vacciner
en priorité ceux qui sont le plus à
risque à risque de faire des formes
graves à haut risque elle est en
réanimation au risque de décéder
et donc c'est notre stratégie c'est on a
commencé avec les ehpad et aujourd'hui
on ouvre pour les personnes de plus 75
ans ou qui ont des facteurs de
vulnérabilité
évidemment nous sommes dépendants du
rythme de production sachant que c'est
très important de le dire qu'à paris de
pénurie en soi est un premier un enjeu
de vacciner au rythme la production de
cash chaque fois que il ya des vaccins
qui sort des lignes de production ils
sont répartis en europe et au plus vite
on les répartit sur le territoire pour
vacciner quand j'ai débuté sa carrière
européenne est trop important on le voit
dès ce week end qui a beaucoup de
demandes de rendez vous il ya déjà cinq
cent mille personnes qui ont pris rendez
vous ça fait plus d'un million de rendez
vous c'est que c'est pour ça qu'à la fin
de sa force c'est pour ça que tous les
jeudis olivier ferrand le premie nice
vous présente le planning de livraison
des vaccins et savait que j'entendais
xavier bertrand dire il suffit de
convoquer les patrons des grands
laboratoires pour les vaccins arrivent
c'est un peu oublié ce qui est à la fois
l'enjeu de sécurité sanitaire de
production industrielle moi quand
j'étais mis affaires européennes oui au
printemps dernier
avec le président république on avait un
enjeu c'était d'éviter une guerre de
tous contre tous où chacun se serait
battu avec les industriels et
pharmaceutiques pour avoir les vaccins
en plus grand nombre que ses voisins
sous prétexte qu'ils paieraient plus ou
qu'il aurait mieux négocier on a ça je
crois que c'est vraiment une vraie
réussite
aujourd'hui on n'est pas dans une guerre
de cause tous contre tous pour faire la
course au vaccin
on a un accord qui nous couvre tous les
27 pays de l'union
et avec tous les pays européens nous
travaillons justement à ce qu'à chaque
fois qu'il ya des vaccins qui sortent
ils soient répartis entre les européens
unis est ce qu'il y n'y a donc pas de
stratégie de commandes en dehors de
l'union européenne aucun pays ni de la
france non ça c'est vraiment un objectif
c'est le président avait parlé du vaccin
bien public mondial
en dix ans chaque personne a la vocation
à être protégée non pas en fonction de
son passeport et parce que c'est une
personne qui est vue mais a par exemple
est donc aujourd'hui c'est un pacte de
confiance de solidarité et d'efficacité
qui est très fort entre tous les pays
européens
quand les vaccins sort des usines ils
sont répartis en fonction la population
par pays européens et ensuite au sein de
la france ils sont à nouveau répartis
par département en fonction la
population mais est-ce qu'il faut s'en
tenir à ce pacte européen quitte à
manquer de doses ou est ce que comme le
dit le même avis bertrand que vous citez
bien il faut passer hors de l'europe est
commandée à n'importe quel et moi je
suis persuadé que si on était passé en
de l'europe et si on avait tenu ce
raisonnement départ aujourd'hui on
serait dans une situation très difficile
tous parce qu'on serait tout le temps en
train de se battre entre nous je sais
qu'aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'on est en
train européen qu'on a réussi à demander
un stand industriel d'accélérer les
cadences d'accélérer les livraisons et
dans quelques semaines ça se verra donc
je pense que l'europe sur ce coup là et
sur beaucoup d'autres en fait on est
beaucoup plus fort on est beaucoup plus
crédible et surtout on assure une
solidarité je crois humaine entre nous
qui est nécessaire dans une crise
sanitaire
alors puisqu'on parle de l'europe il ya
des questions qui se posent sur les
frontières un jean castex l'a rappelé
frontière fermée entre guillemets les
frontières de l'espace schengen sont
fermés mais au sein de l'espace schengen
les frontières sont ouvertes est ce que
pour vous il faut renforcer
drastiquement les contrôles vienne
héritière au sein de l'espace schengen
depuis le début cette crise il ya deux
mots clés coopération efficacité et donc
il ya des réunions qui se tiendront
cette semaine pour voir comment on est
efficace
tout en étant coopératif ce avec le but
c'est pas de prendre des mesures au
style des uns vis-à-vis des autres il ya
des flux je pense notamment à tous les
flux transfrontaliers entre gt oui dans
les ardennes vendredi
évidemment il faut qu'on puisse
conserver un niveau de circulation qui
permettent la vie quotidienne notamment
ceux qui travaillent de leur côté de la
frontière mais donc tous ces enjeux-là
seront discutés notamment clément bonne
à ce nombre de réunions dont je connais
bien la nature parce que je sais ça a
été une partie de mon côté je viens
demain c'est pour ça qu'on est donc à
chaque fois depuis depuis le début dans
cette crise on cherche à être efficace
pas faire du symbole la fin du symbole
pas faire gagner le primat de ce fait
pas quelle idée parce qu'on
conceptuellement on dirait que c'est
efficace
d'abord qu'est-ce qui est vraiment
efficace et surtout comment on le fait
de manière coopérative et sauf qu'au
sein même de l'espace schengen au sein
de son au sein de l'ue des pays de
l'union européenne il ya des pays qui
contrôlent plus de frontières c'est pas
ça on est trop là c'est sûr ça qu'il est
important d'avoir des raisons de
coopération pour qu'on harmonise nos
pratiques et qu'on le fasse mes critères
objectifs
est ce que c'est le taux d'incidence du
point de départ vers un taux d'incidence
- un dernier point d'arrivée bref je
vais vous faire des discussions
techniques mais c'est très important à
nouveau de fonder tous ses décisions sur
des critères objectifs et donc c'est
tout ce qui est en train de se passer et
je rencontre l'harmoniser mes contrôles
renforcés pour vous il faudrait on verra
comment ça se déroule et qu'est-ce qui
est conclue mais objectivité efficacité
et coopération et c'est comme ça que
l'europe avance d'ailleurs c'est comme
ça que sur les vaccins j'y reviens on a
réussi aujourd'hui je crois avant une
situation qui est sécurisante pour
chaque européen
le niveau de livraisons de vaccins dans
son pays ne dépend pas de son passeport
et ça je crois que c'est aussi une
victoire aux pêches le mans à propos de
passeport le passeport vaccinale ça
serait pas moyen efficace de régler
circulation les français ils sont plutôt
favorables
vous même qu'en dites vous moi je dis
d'abord que c'est un sujet qui n'est pas
aujourd'hui sur la table puisque
aujourd'hui on vous l'a bien vu tous
ceux qui voudraient se faire vacciner ne
le sont pas encore donc je pense qu'il
faut là aussi ne pas créer ni les
polémiques ni de l'anxiété et donc c'est
bien d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on a besoin
de règles de circulation qui dépend de
faits objectifs
on parle de cette campagne de
vaccination qui a été beaucoup critiquée
notamment à ses débuts sur la lenteur de
la campagne est ce que pour vous
l'administration est en partie
responsable de la lenteur au démarrage
de cette campagne de vaccination sur ce
sujet j'aime bref vous présentez un peu
la doctrine générale d'actions d'un
gouvernement qui prend ses
responsabilités vous avez des gens ont
s'agira un marché qui invente des
complexités qui vous viennent maintenant
je vais pas d'autres télé vous dire
voilà c'est scandaleux le consentement
50 pap
ça c'est de l'invention puis il ya eu
des problèmes et il ya des problèmes
réels dans la vie quotidienne parfois
entre une stratégie et sa mise en oeuvre
il faut que nos ministres soient
extrêmement vigilants sur la manière
dont très finement sur le terrain
partout en france les choses se déploie
et notre rôle de responsable politique
d'un ciseau ce mot c'est pas de nous
entêter c'est pas de fermer les yeux
c'est pas de dire non tout va bien quand
c'est pas manifestement pas le cas c'est
de nous ajuster cette corriger le tir
c'est de faire en sorte que les choses
fonctionnent donc est ce qu'il ya eu des
lourdeurs sûrement et celles qui
existaient ont été réglés d'ailleurs
pour ça que hier il y avait quatre cent
vingt mille personnes qui ont été
vaccinées en france
mais pourquoi ils ont été vaccinées
parce qu'à un moment donné le président
la république le premier ministre le miz
la santé ont joué leur rôle de politique
le rôle du politique c'est pas ni de
faire une confiance aveugle à
l'administration ni des dans la défiance
permanente c'est de dire on a nous les
responsabilités ont défini une stratégie
et on doit se soucier du détail de la
commande dans l'exécution fine les
choses se passent ne se passe pas -
voyez je ne serai pas la ministre qui
viendra vous dire c'est scandaleux
comme certains jeux comme je les appelle
les états tôt log les grands personnes
qui font la science de la réforme de
l'état ou des anciens ministres comme
montebourg qui vous expliquent que si
l'administration de bercy il avait plus
écoutés ils auraient réussi ça c'est
irresponsable
c'est en fait assez lâches c'est même
assez facile la responsabilité elle est
où elle est dans celui qui pilote
l'administration qui pilotent
l'administration c'est le ministre est
donc un ministre et de président de la
république nous le rappelle à chaque
jour chaque semaine chaque conseil des
ministres nous avons la responsabilité
non seulement de définir des stratégies
non seulement de faire voter des lois
mais surtout et avant tout nous assurer
qu'elles s'appliquent réellement
pratiquement dans tous les territoires
d'ailleurs pour ça que le baromètre des
résultats qu'on a présenté la semaine
dernière va exactement là on va y venir
mais puisque vous parlez de confiance de
défiance quand
un recours à un cabinet un privé comme
ça a été le cas de la part du
gouvernement pour prendre cette décision
parce que c'est pas un sentiment de
défiance vis-à-vis de l'administration
française mais c'est pourquoi on va
chercher des avis extérieurs
parce que quand on doit gérer une crise
quand on doit faire la logistique avec
des produits qui se transporte à moins
80 degrés vous avez des gens qui ont à
la fois une vision de ce qui se passe
dans d'autres pays
dans d'autres secteurs qui peuvent
apporter une expérience moi je pense que
c'est sain c'est sans que
l'administration avait cherché des avis
extérieurs c'est les ministres les uns
après les autres demandé à vie dans des
missions à les experts pas parce que on
n'aurait pas les compétences en interne
et parce que pour prendre de bonnes
décisions des décisions éclairées
on a aussi besoin d'être confronté à
d'autres manières de faire quand on est
en juin quand on est en pleine crise je
pense que c'est c'est pas du tout un
scandale au contraire qu'on aille
chercher des avis extérieurs techniques
précis les personnes en question de vous
parler c'est pas elle qui devrait les
décisions elle nous aide à prendre
justement des avis extérieurs et donc
évidemment on a ensuite un enjeu de
recrutement mais aux fonctionnaires de
formation de variété des profils
on y travaille avec le président
république sur la réforme de la haute
fonction publique
l'évaluation de fonction il ya encore
beaucoup de choses à faire je vais pas
nier devant vous que j'ai beaucoup de
travail et qu'on me demande de faire
beaucoup de choses et qu'évidemment il
ya encore énormément de transformation à
faire le 4 février prochain au tour du
premier ministre
tous les ministres sont réunis pour
tirer les leçons d'organisation de
fonctionnement interne à nos
administrations sur les ajustements
apprendre des choses qu'on a ajusté
pendant la crise et qu'on veut rendre
pérenne ou des choses qu'il faudrait
encore qu'on a juste pour être plus
efficace que ce soit sur les sujets
sanitaires ou les sujets de réformes
donc je vais pas nier devant vous les
évidences mais arrêtons un de nous
inventer des problèmes qui n'existent
pas ce marché
arrêtons de penser que l'administration
serait devenue folle nos mairies plus
aux politiques et commentons une forme
d'impuissance politique monsieur
montebourg
arrêtons ça
les politiciens votre collègue
effectivement bruno le maire disait en
début de semaine sur france inter il
employer cette expression de mon archi
technocratique moi je suis pas d'accord
avec cette expression pour cela bordeaux
nantes démocratie tout dépend où darchy
et la technocratie ce serait l'idée
selon laquelle les mistons plus drôle je
suis aussi très fortement convaincu
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons un grand rôle
celui de piloter nos administrations
donc ils se trompent bruno le maire je
suis pas d'accord et que cette
expression après on a plein de débat et
vous imaginez bien qu'on cherche tous
d'ailleurs a trouvé de l'efficacité et
donc c'est plutôt ça qui me semble être
un sujet de débats autour des
expressions oui donc depuis quelques
semaines l'arrêt de travail automatique
est mise en place
avez vous évalué dans la fonction
publique
combien de fonctionnaires et quel
pourcentage sont en arrêt de travail
alors on l'a évalué tout le second
confinement je peux vous dire le à un
moment donné on avait 0 2% à 0 3% des
agents de l'état qui ne pouvait pas
travailler parce qu'ils étaient soit
qu'à contacter soit parce qu'ils étaient
d'ailleurs en arrêt parce que le lieu où
il travaillait était fermé oui donc on
était à 99 7 ou 99 8 % des agents de
l'état qui travaillait donc on suit ça
bien sûr avec beaucoup de vigilance
cet arrêt de travail il est important
parce qu'il permet d'être extrêmement
efficace dans l' isolement qu'on demande
à tous ceux qui pensent qu'ils ont des
symptômes avant un test qui sont qu'à
contacter ou qui sont eux mêmes malade
il a un intérêt également c'est qu'il
respecte secret médical
votre employeur public au privé c'est
que vous êtes arrêté qui a pas de jour
de carence vous n'avez pas de
conséquences financières mais ne sais
pas si c'est parce que vous êtes un
contact ou positif c'est important de
notre pays l'employeur ne sache pas si
vous êtes malade et de court il ay les
récents c'est s'est mise en place depuis
le 10 janvier vigeant inactif depuis le
10 janvier sur le nom de fonctionnaires
qui ont eu recours non vous savez je
pense que on va suivre les choses
évidemment
moi je fais d'ailleurs confiance aux
français sur le fait qu' évidemment dès
qu'ils ont des symptômes ils s'arrêtent
ils se font tester il s'isole et le but
soyez c'est pas de faire un pilotage par
le chiffre le but c'est de stopper
l'épidémie
et donc si à un moment donné il ya
beaucoup de gens qui doivent s'isoler et
bien il vaut mieux qu'on le fasse plutôt
qu'on pilote ça il sait pas un enjeu de
performances ça moi je de stopper
l'épidémie 1 sur les termes à travailler
le télétravail va mais toujours
combien de fonctionnaires le pratiquer
on a on est monté jusqu'à peu près 45 %
des agents de l'état hors enseignants
pendant l'automne là au début de l'année
on est autour de 35% donc à nouveau
champ qu'il ya aussi des personnes qui
ont eu besoin psychologique mans de
revenir comme ces pauvres comme ces
permis ou comme c'est possible surtout
un jour par semaine sur le travail pour
mettre fin au fond aussi beaucoup
d'isolement
donc on continue bien sûr de faire du
télétravail à la fois un outil de lutte
contre la pandémie
c'est aussi plus structurellement une
évolution des méthodes de travail de la
confiance managériale et donc vous
pouvez compter sur notre envie d'aller
plus loin et d'ailleurs de négocier
comme c'était cas dans le secteur privé
mais donc c'est un public un nouveau
cadre sur le télétravail pérenne qui
nous occupera avec les organes
syndicales et les employeurs dans les
prochaines semaines à quelle échéance ce
nouveau cas le but c'est d'avoir au
printemps quelque chose de stabiliser
qui nous permettent de nous organiser en
cas de crise mais aussi en temps normal
je crois que on a vu à la fois les
bénéfices ut dry mais aussi les limites
et donc il faut qu'on puisse pas se
donner un cadre qui permet à tous de
trouver à la fois la confiance mais
derrière on voit bien que c'est les
pratiques manageriales c'est comment on
gère une équipe comment on gère comme on
conceptualise même le travail ça veut
dire quoi travailler ensemble et pas
forcément parce qu'on vient en sueur sur
le travail que les choses fonctionnent
au mieux donc c'est aussi un outil
intéressant de transformation des
pratiques
un dernier mot sur ce sujet avant de
passer aux réformes sur les
complémentaires santé pour les
fonctionnaires la hausse il va y avoir
des nouvelles mesures exactement ce
matin c'est un moment important où nous
réunissons tous les employeurs publics
et je réunis les organes sur syndicales
pour un conseil commun la fonction
publique qui va acter le fait qu'on a
une ordonnance donc à un texte
législatif sur la table qui va permettre
que d'ici 2026 tous les agents publics
et une prise en charge à 50% de la
complémentaire santé ça commence en 2022
dans l'état avec 12 à 15 euros par mois
pour tous les agents publics qu'ils
soient contractuels qu'ils soient
titulaires
parce que là aussi après une crise
sanitaire et des inégalités qui était
objectivement pas acceptable c'est pas
normal que quand vous êtes dans le privé
votre employeur paye 50 % des mutuelles
et que dans le public aujourd'hui qui
est des endroits on n'avait quasiment
pas voir pas du tout prise en charge
donc c'est un sujet celui qu'on a
beaucoup travaillé son engagement que
j'avais pris en juillet de conclure
cette réforme est donc elle sera elle
était dans la loi de 2019 comme une
éventualité
c'est maintenant une réalité que nous
actons ce matin et justement va parler
du bilan des réformes pascal wii dont
j'ai mis en place un baromètre des
réformes dans la fonction publique
alors où en êtes vous de ce baromètre et
quel est son objectif
donc ce baromètre il est sur le site du
gouvernement donc tous les citoyens
français peuvent aller sur la page du
gouvernement de rentrer leur code postal
et département par département
ils peuvent savoir ce qui s'est passé
dans leur vie quotidienne dans leur
département de changements depuis trois
ans ça peut être des questions sur
l'accès à la santé les maisons de santé
l'accès aux services publics les enjeux
d'éducation des enfants les enjeux de
transition écologique c'est vraiment 25
réforme chantier de la vie quotidienne
où nous présentons ce qui a avancé et
peut-être qu'il ya moins avancés
pourquoi on fait ça on fait ça parce
qu'on nous envoie la transparence aux
français ça aussi un enjeu de confiance
à quoi ça sert de voter si personne ne
vous rend compte des actions qui sont
prises après les lois qui sont votées au
sénat à l'assemblée et après les débats
parlementaires les départs volontaires
ils ont un objectif c'est de faire
changer la vie quotidienne s'est pas
d'occuper des sénateurs et députés donc
d'abord par la transparence rétablir la
confiance et c'est ensuite aussi un
outil d'accélération comment dans les 18
prochains mois
tous les endroits où on pense que les
résultats sont pas à la hauteur de nos
attentes ou de nos objectifs on se donne
les moyens d'accélérer en mettant les
faits ont mis la table pour en fait ça
parce que des gens de l'opposition
ici à paris madame hidalgo monsieur
jacob monsieur larcher qui vous disent
là on n'aurait rien fait au genre on ne
fait rien ou alors la crise sanitaire de
façon tout arrêter et vite vite 2022
pour qu'on change tout ça j'étais dans
les ardennes vendredi n'a réuni tous les
élus locaux tous les élus départementaux
régionaux communaux des ardennes la
discussion que j'avais que c'est pas une
discussion sur les présidentielles c'est
pas sûr on n'a rien fait on n'a pas fait
c'est comment la en 2021
maintenant sur des enjeux ou
l'apprentissage la réussite des
étudiants à l'université les choses du
territoire l'accès à la fibre
oui injuste sur le territoire de grosses
disparités par exemple sur l'accès à la
fibre vous venez d'en parler il y à des
nordistes
arrêtez d'un département à l'autre ça
comment vous faites voulu rectifier tout
de suite dont évidemment consigne est ce
qu'on voit c'est quoi c'est que
l'ensemble des chantiers au niveau
national et en moyenne progresse si on
s'en tenait là on pourrait
s'autocongratuler c'est parce qu'on
cherche à faire ce compte des charges à
faire c'est à dire ça progresse ma part
y ait des endroits où il faut qu'on soit
beaucoup plus vigilants peut-être qu'on
mette plus de moyens
peut-être qu'on accompagne plus ces
choses peut-être qu'on secoue un peu le
système peut être que les gens se sont
collectivement un peu endormi ses
actions elle nécessite beaucoup de
travail de coordination entre différents
acteurs entre différents élus entre
entre l'état parfois des entreprises
privées telles qu'un la fibre et
notamment on peut avec le plan de
relance 6 a besoin de moyens financiers
supplémentaires accéléré sur la fibre le
pr ministre et dans l'allier ce week end
il annonce que dans le plan de relance
il ya 500 besoin de 10 millions d'euros
pour accélérer déploiement de la fibre
et dans l'allier il ya 39 % des
habitants qui ont la fibre et le
département ni de france mais 80% c'est
pas acceptable parce que c'est une
politique où tous les français pourront
voit le télétravail pour l'accès les
enfants à l'éducation sur des nouvelles
possibilités pour développer son
entreprise
on a tous besoin est aujourd'hui
connectés donc pour confessa
transparence accélération et
l'accélération peut notamment venir du
plan de relance mais pas que et donc ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que les élus
que j'ai rencontrés au fond ces
objectifs ils sont partagé tous les élus
de terrain tous les français ont tous
très envie et il voit bien que c'est
urgent que je vous dis sur
l'apprentissage se la fibre sur l'accès
aux services publics dans tous les
territoires les choses progressent et
c'est important pour nous agresser d'ici
la fin du quinquennat ou est ce que vous
dites mais il ya des réformes on pourra
pas réussir d'ici la fin du quinquennat
d'abord ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'il ya énormément des résultats qui
sont publiés aujourd'hui qu'ils sont le
fruit de l'action de 2020 donc 2020
c'est pas été une année où je dire le
courant n'a virus a tout effacé bien sûr
que la crise rempli une partie de nos
vies mais nos vies ne se résume pas à la
crise la vie quotidienne des français
tous les gays en jeu dont je vous parle
sont des enjeux qui resteront d'ailleurs
après la crise et les français seront
bien en droit de nous demander qu'est ce
qu'on a fait et donc nous notre objectif
n'est pas de faire diversion
concernant ghz à vous êtes en train de
vous parler d'autre chose pour nous
tourner le regard de la crise sanitaire
mais c'est tout c'est tout l'inversé
pour sortir la crise on a besoin
accéléré est ce que je peux vous dire
c'est pour être tout à fait le temps en
18 mois d'aller dans les dix
département qui sur telles politiques
publiques ont manifestement un peu un
retard à l'allumage ou des difficultés
de concentrer nos moyens notre notre
soutien politique aussi un peu de
pression constructive pour que les
choses avancent et je crois que les
français sont en demande non seulement
de résultats mais de résultats dans tous
les territoires ce que ce baromètre
montre et d'ailleurs les gilet jaune
jade manière avait déjà tiré la sonnette
d'alarmé c'est que en moyenne les choses
peuvent aller plutôt bien mais que
certains territoires sont victimes c'est
une façon de vraies inégalités sait
jamais les mêmes territoires
j'ai pas de l'endroit où rien ne se
passe mais dans chaque territoire vous
avez des forces et des faiblesses qu'il
faut qu'on corrige avec un esprit
constructif et coopérative avec les élus
locaux puisque vous parlez des français
on sait que le gouvernement est bien
associer les citoyens à ces réformes est
ce que là les citoyens seront associés
au suivi de tout à fait on met de la
mise en place aujourd'hui oui je
rencontre un panel de citoyens qui
représente plusieurs départements pour
échanger sur l'outil est ensuite dans
chacun de mes déplacements à partir de
voiliers vendredi en charente
et bien il y aura un moment de ce tour
de france que je que je fais ou non
seulement oui je vois les services de
l'état je vois bien sûr tous les élus
mais je rencontre aussi des citoyens
pour que on s'assure que la photo qu'on
leur donne de la réalité correspondent à
leur perception parfois d'ailleurs avoir
un échange sur la manière dont il voit
différemment les choses que ce qu'on
leur met comme étant des faits et s'est
défait de choses observables et puis
aussi pour parler ces réformes comment
il les voit comment ils les comprennent
comment peut-être il faut qu'on
simplifie l'information genre que c'est
très important quand vous dites on fait
ça pour les français dans leur vie
quotidienne
donc c'est pas à envoyer des grandes
réformes qui sont pilotés depuis paris
depuis juste nos bureaux ministériels
c'est sur le terrain que ça se passe et
dernière question pascal oui alors
justement toutes ces réformes mais
yat-il encore le temps d'engager deux
grandes réformes
bon là il y en a d'autres qui viennent
la loi quant au séparatisme islamistes
on va avoir la loi environnement est-ce
que ça suffit pas et y at il le temps
d'engager d'autres réformes sociales
économiques
la première chose c'est déjà mettre en
oeuvre dans tous les territoires pour
tous les français tous qu'on a lancé
c'est absolument essentiel joué la
confiance démocratique et je crois que
c'est une réforme en soi beaucoup de
gouvernements sont arrêtés avant de
faire ce travail et vient de finition et
on sait que la finition que ça compte
beaucoup parce que ça qui fait qu'à la
fin les objectifs sont atteints ou pas
ensuite évidemment sur le séparatisme
évidemment sur le cloud le climat on a
d'ailleurs devant nous des techniques
importants est-ce qu'il faut s'arrêter
là le président la république est un
membre est il bien sûr un chômage il y
en a d'autres
on n'est pas d'humeur à s'arrêter on
essaie de faire le maximum il faut que
les conditions soient réunies pour que
ça puisse se faire mais nous sommes un
gouvernement qui jusqu'au bout ne
prendra jamais le prétexte à crise
sanitaire pour arrêter l'ambition
transformatrices qui est la nôtre est
donc évidemment il ya encore beaucoup
beaucoup de choses des français le
savent
sur lesquels on doit progresser donc on
va continuer merci beaucoup merci il est
nonchalant d'être venu nous voir ce
matin merci pascal jallet on regarde la
une du dauphiné libéré c'est
l'infectiologue iséroise karine la
conquête à la une de votre journal
on a bon espoir d'un retour à la
normalité au deuxième semestre 2000 21
ans il s'agit maintenant que oui voilà
c'est un peu l'objectif de tout le monde
que ça se passe bien partir du mois de
juin pour que les français troisième
trimestre entre guillemets normal et
voilà c'est à dire dans le dauphiné
libéré merci beaucoup merci - de
montchalin d'être venu nous voir on
passe aussitôt club des territoires la
mutuelle nationale territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux vous présente le club des
territoires
angie acteurs engagés n'aurait
transition zéro carbone des régions vous
présente le club des territoires
[Musique]